[Music]
on monday morning rumors had emerged
that brown's running back kareem hunt
had been involved in some sort of an
altercation outside of a bar in
cleveland those rumors eventually became
video obtained by who else tmz of kareem
hunt talking to police officers who
seemed to be responding to some sort of
an altercation whether it was serious
whether it was horse play between hunt
and a friend it's unclear at this point
and it's unclear whether anything
happens from here but a couple of key
points to keep in mind number one hunt
has an eight-game suspension that he is
due to serve at the start of this season
for violating the personal conduct
policy and given that cowboys running
back ezekiel elliott back in new york on
tuesday to meet with the commissioner
after his latest incident that we saw
thanks to a tmz obtained video of elliot
in the face of a security guard at a
music festival in las vegas the nfl will
be more inclined to respond aggressively
if the nfl thinks that someone who's
already gotten in trouble has done
something else that potentially
constitutes more trouble and that's
where this becomes potentially
fascinating as it relates to the
cleveland browns because nobody knows
what kind of arrangement the browns
created with hunt when they signed him
earlier this year months after he'd been
cut by the chiefs and the browns may
have said to kareem hunt look one more
false move and we don't care what it is
you don't even have to cross the line if
you just get in the vicinity of the line
if your name comes up in connection to
anything remotely negative you're out if
they put that strong of a restriction
upon him as it relates to him getting
involved in any type of off-field issues
this possibly would be enough to get the
browns to move on from him of course
they're not going to admit that to us
unless they go ahead and cut him
they could be in this sweet spot where
they told him that
but
now that it's happened we're going to
give him another chance because here's
the reality talent continues to secure
additional chances and because kareem
hunt was the nfl's leading rusher in
2017 and the browns feel like they have
stolen this guy off of the free agent
market and he can come in and he can
make a big impact for the browns as they
try to live up to their heightened
expectations maybe the browns do give
him yet another second chance even
though they may have told him when he
was signed earlier this year one false
move and you're gone
there's plenty of discretion involved in
deciding what is and what isn't a false
move and it could be that the browns
decide given the lack of any hard
evidence of any type of real misconduct
and no evidence of hunt doing anything
that someone could argue he shouldn't
have been doing
chances are the browns are going to keep
doing what they've been doing wait for
the eight-game suspension to end and
welcome kareem hunt back into the fold
for a stretch run that could involve
ultimately the first playoff appearance
for the cleveland browns since
2002 just up the road from cleveland is
canton ohio site of the pro football
hall of fame now in connection with the
100th anniversary of the national
football league not the 100th season got
to keep it straight this is the 100th
season next year is the 100th
anniversary next year they are expanding
the class of hall of famers they
essentially and look i i
they're using this occasion the
combination of nostalgia and overall
feeling good about football as an excuse
to clean up some past messes expanding
the class of senior
candidate hall of famers guys who have
been overlooked over the years who don't
have the same chances of modern era
finalists to get into the hall of fame
they're going to go back and they're
going to basically hand out these golden
tickets to guys that the voters believe
they should have gotten in during the
normal course of affairs it's going to
result in a huge class of hall of famers
it could result in a very cumbersome
hall of fame induction process and you
know it's brought back to my mind
something i've talked about recently
both on pftm and pftpm and pft live and
it's this
i think the bar needs to be higher when
it comes to who gets into the pro
football hall of fame and i i believe at
some level there are very important
business reasons that result in five
modern era finalists all of them getting
in every year when have we ever heard of
a modern era finalist not ultimately
getting in when you get down to the
final five they show up to consider 15
on that saturday before the super bowl
it's whittled to ten it gets whittled to
five you get to the five you're getting
in because every guy that you get in
that's one less guy you have to worry
about getting in in the future and it
reduces that log jam you don't want to
waste those five slots by turning one or
two guys away and shrinking the size of
the class because then that just creates
even bigger messes down the road and so
much of this is processing these names
getting these guys that they think are
good enough to get into the hall of fame
into the hall of fame but always having
that class of five and what that does is
when you throw on the other three now
whether it's two senior committee
candidates and one contributor or two
contributors and one senior what it
creates is this very
robust and meaningful weekend of
festivities every year in canton ohio
and if you would set a higher bar that
would result in
three total members of the class maybe
two maybe one maybe not maybe there'd be
a year with no hall of famers what does
that do to the canton economy what does
that do to the level of interest at the
pro football hall of fame and i really
do feel like and it should this shock
anyone the whole thing's a business
there's a strong business component to
the hall of fame and they are seizing
upon next year's 100th anniversary as a
way to take care of some old business
and clean up those messes i mentioned to
earlier where guys that they believe
should have gotten in in the past under
this lower than it should be standard of
what is a hall of famer
all in the name of of making that that
museum more attractive making that
weekend even bigger and ultimately
making more money for everyone involved
i hate to be that cynical but i just i
really do believe the bar should be
higher and i think the people who should
get into the hall of fame are the ones
about whom there really shouldn't be
much of a debate and uh
there's a lot of these close questions
and i think the closer the question the
less likely the person should be in the
hall of fame in the first pl first place
that may not be a popular take that's
never stopped me in the past i just
think that the bar needs to be pushed a
lot higher and for next year they are
definitely going to be lowering the bar
to get in some names that they have
failed to get in
in the past one guy who's destined to
get into the hall of fame when he's
finally eligible and that would be five
years after he last plays in an nfl game
would be patriots tight end rob
gronkowski there's been a lot of
speculation that maybe he'll come back
and play during the season well if he's
going to be doing that folks
gronk better be ingesting plenty of
protein shakes and all sorts of other
calories and fat to put his body back
together because this guy is looking
down right svelt several months after
last playing in the national football
league i don't know he looks 30 or 40
pounds lighter so you know i thought
there was a chance he would give into
the temptation at some point in october
or november to come back and play if
he's looking like he does in that in
that little clip that we just played
i
i don't think he's going to be able to
give into that temptation he's already
made the decision by shrinking his body
to something far smaller than what we're
accustomed to seeing and i'm surprised
he's done it because
for whatever is this guy plans to do
gronk being wrong i thought it was
premised on gronk being gronk which
means not just this happy-go-lucky
doofus but a guy who's cut and chiseled
and can flash his guns and can use that
physique as a marketing device we've
speculated for a while about gronk being
the the star of a reboot of the
terminator which would be a great entry
into acting for him because it entailed
for arnold schwarzenegger about 17 total
lines much of most of which were just a
couple of syllables if you don't have
the body to pull it off
not going to be the star of the reboot
of the terminator and you know wrestling
and even if he's just a figurehead in
wrestling and doesn't get into the ring
you you want to see that gronk size you
want to see that overall gronk vibe and
it was kind of surprising to see how
small he is and it it really if anything
closes doors it doesn't open them and
the one door it closes is that door of
temptation that could lead him back to
the national football league during the
2019 season because before he could come
back he really would have to start
putting some of those pounds back on one
guy who's been out of the nfl since the
2016 season that's quarterback colin
kaepernick look i i firmly believe he's
never going to be back in the nfl i
think that the deal that was done to
settle his collusion grievance the
magnitude of the payment that was made
it tells me the nfl's not worried about
any further legal action the nfl has no
desire to ever bring him back but he
still has influence as seen by what
happened earlier this week when nike was
planning to issue a shoe that had the
original united states flag on it with
the 13 stars the so-called betsy ross
flag well colin kaepernick who has had a
very lucrative arrangement with nike
over the past year and nike has seen its
sales
increase in its stock value also climb
as a result of the kaepernick
relationship kaepernick contact nike
said
can't have this that original american
flag too closely associated with an
unfortunate era in america where slavery
was rampant and
look for me
the confederate flag
absolutely positively shouldn't see it
shouldn't be displayed people shouldn't
be riding around with it
out of the back of their trucks they
shouldn't have a tattooed on their
bodies they shouldn't be wearing the
t-shirt they shouldn't be flying it
because that has a clear connotation to
some of the most unfortunate days of
american history but
the original flag that's a tougher cell
the original flag with the stars
representing the 13 colonies i mean you
could argue that nike shouldn't have
been selling
the shoe with that flag on it because
the flag's never supposed to be used as
a peril of any kind it's a more nuanced
point that that flag hearkens to a time
in the united states where there were
atrocities happening as it relates to
the ownership and the treatment of
slaves but does that mean we shut down
the entire first century of american
history or at least until
slavery ended i i don't know i don't
know the answer to that question my
point is this kaepernick still has
plenty of juice and he
exercised it by getting nike to back off
of issuing that shoe and now nike's got
an issue in arizona because the governor
there isn't thrilled with what's
happened and the governor has vowed to
take away tax credits for nike and it
becomes a political football now no pun
intended but you know that that's what
happens and some people think this was
all a setup by nike i really don't think
so i think that the the people there saw
no problem with embracing american
history and that original
stars and stripes with the 13 stars
arranged in a circle by betsy ross i
you know it's it's it's
it's not a mainstream thought that
there's a problem with it and
kaepernick's influence has pulled kind
of a fringe belief into the mainstream
and nike has agreed whether to what
extent those agree remains to be seen
but for now nike has agreed and for
fourth of july week we have an issue
that maybe nobody expected to become an
issue
during uh this summer if at all in 2019.
all right one last topic before we go
2019 is a target for the nfl to get a
new collective bargaining agreement in
place the league would like to have it
in place before the start of the regular
season i don't think that's practical i
think best case scenario is to have a
new cba in place before the next super
bowl but be that as it may a term to get
accustomed to because you're going to
hear a lot of it as these negotiations
heat up and as proposals begin to be
exchanged by the nfl players association
and the national football league and the
phrase is this
stadium credits see ultimately at the
core of any cba between the nfl and the
nfl pa is how they split up the money
now before 2011 the players were getting
60
that sounds good but it was 60 percent
of the net after the owners took a lot
of money off of the top for all sorts of
other things
now the players are getting under the
2011 cba roughly 47
of the gross
well moving forward what owners would
like to do is take more money off the
top to help pay for construction and
renovation of stadiums and the players
look at it and they say
why don't we want to be in that business
the owners provide the workplace we
provide the work why should we be paying
with money that otherwise would be
distributed to all players through the
salary cap mechanism
money that
is going to go to pay for the stadiums
that's not our deal that's not our gig
here's the problem the owners may be
intent on pushing that issue
aggressively enough
that they would lock the players out
over it so if the owners are serious
about it and they want some allowance
for stadium credits what do the players
do here's one way to look at it
if you're the players
and the league expects you to chip in
for the renovation and construction of
stadiums specifically as it relates to
the construction of stadiums the players
need a say
and where these stadiums are going to be
constructed that creates a a fascinating
new dynamic
as we look at
the
game of stadium construction and whether
or not teams will relocate if they can't
get the kind of public money they want
and does it make business sense to build
a new stadium in a small market when
there's a bigger market out there where
everyone can make more money and and now
should the players if they're going to
be paying for the stadiums
should they have a seat at the table
when it comes to those deliberations as
to where
nfl stadiums should be constructed look
at buffalo and folks i i know bills fans
get very very sensitive to any
suggestion that there may not be a new
stadium built in buffalo and that the
stadium where the bills play at some
point could be built somewhere else but
think about this if the nfl pa is going
to be expected to devote a chunk of
money that otherwise would go to players
to construction of a new bill stadium
shouldn't the nflpa have a say in
whether or not that stadium is built in
buffalo or somewhere else maybe
collectively the players don't want to
live and work in buffalo no offense to
buffalo but if the players don't want to
live and work there and they're
partially paying for the stadium
maybe that ends up being a factor in how
this all plays out i guess my point is
for the nfl be careful what you wish for
because
if you want players to contribute to the
construction of stadiums you have to
give them a voice you can't just say we
blindly want the money and we'll figure
out how to use it best and if you do
give them a voice how do you keep them
from basically hijacking the process and
saying you know what
we'd rather have a team in st louis st
louis is putting together some public
money it's going to cost us less and you
less and we're going to make more money
in st louis because it's a bigger market
than buffalo
i think if you open that door
and the players become partners not just
in the sport specifically but in how the
sport is presented via that construction
of stadiums
things could get
intriguing to say the least
and
all of a sudden instead of what the
owner wants because that's what it's
always been what's the owner want the
owner wants to stay the owner wants to
move the owner wants this the owner
wants that the players are kicking in
significant money
for these stadiums significant enough
money that maybe they would be locked
out if they refuse to kick in the money
and they get a voice
maybe players start dictating where
teams are going to be
and the more i think about it
i
i wonder why it hasn't been that case in
the past why is it that the people who
own the teams decide where the teams are
going to be why isn't it that the
players the ones who have to live and
work in those communities don't have
more of a say
if you expect the players to pay
for
a large chunk of the new stadiums that
are going to be built maybe they should
have that say and maybe this could get a
lot more interesting as these talks
unfold if stadium credits continue to be
an issue and i believe based upon
everything i've heard there will be a
major issue in this ongoing round of cba
negotiations that's it for today's pft
ot remember pfc live is on hiatus until
july 29 but i will be periodically
bringing you video content from the site
of pft live when we are back on the air
and we'll be back on the air soon enough
the pftpn podcast also will be fired up
from time to time over the next few
weeks and no matter what's going on
profotballtalk.com every day multiple
stories all the time even in a slow week
we had a bunch of stories yesterday a
bunch of stories today plenty of call
news rumors analysis and everything else
so we'll see you there and we'll see you
back here again on wednesday for another
edition of pftot
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports